who is more afraid of commitment in
modern dating men or women
women
they're afraid of getting hurt the
pattern of the pattern that we have
created for ourselves ultimately right
dealing with situationships things of
that sort
it one if you've been dealing with a
counterfeit so long how do you recognize
the real right and so we're afraid to
get ourselves emotionally involved and
become vulnerable and intimate with
someone because we don't know if it's
the real deal because we don't know and
we've never been taught how to identify
what the real is so we're afraid because
like they say when men are ready men are
ready period they're committing but now
you look out and there's nothing to
commit to
hmm do you think women really can't tell
the difference between a guy who's going
to settle down and a guy who won't agree
or yeah
in this day and age especially when a
lot of the guys tell the girls up front
like she said I'm just curious out of
the guys just really quick when you guys
were in whole phase of Life did you tell
the girls absolutely I was 100 honest
this is where I'm at in life but they
always try to change you would they get
mad later
[Music]
but I agree I would I I struggle with
the term counterfeit because that
assumes that a man is presenting himself
as a husband candidate or relationship
ready I think oftentimes we see what we
want to see and we blow past what they
say and we end up hurting ourselves but
blaming it on the men
do you think that's true or false I
think that's true I was thinking in
terms of counterfeit relationships not
the men being counterfeits right they've
dealt with so many situationships and
things like that they don't know what a
real relationship looks like right so
even when a guy they have trust issues
right right so what do you mean they
don't know what a real relationship
looks like they've never seen a real
relationship
precisely issues daddy issues trust
issues and to Camille's Point all of her
friends right she's she'll have a real
conversation with them and then two
weeks later they're talking back to the
same guy why because you know what it's
about why do you keep availing yourself
to that process why do we keep going in
these circular motions because we're
comfortable it's comfort with being hurt
right it takes something it takes some
level of vulnerability trust healing to
make ourselves available for something
new and different and because we're
unfamiliar with what that new is going
to be sometimes we're too afraid to open
ourselves up to that story I think we
know we just don't want what we really
should have I I think we want to force
what we want on someone else when if
we're just supposed to be in a regular
relationship we have a hard time
accepting that I think that's more of of
what it is I just I disagree that it's
um well who do you want like Prince
Charming or something I think every girl
does I mean that's how we're socialized
but I think the problem is like you all
said we all grew up before the internet
we were able to look at Pop Culture
entertainment and say oh that's a great
show and it ended there I never in my
wildest dreams expected that I would be
driving a luxury car in my 20s or having
elaborate dates like that was not the
real world but somehow the lines have
been blurred because of culture because
of moms because of whatever and now we
think what we see out there is what
we're supposed to be living over here
and 100 I don't think women modern women
today want Prince Charming who do they
want they want Superman
they want to take Superman and make them
Clark Kent
but they just don't want Clark Kent they
want to tame Superman they want to tame
the alpha they want the alpha to want
them and only them in a monogamous
relationship and they don't want Prince
Charming off of deck I go over my
channel time and time again
good guys nice guys
petalizing them being simps giving them
the world and then they get sh upon they
don't want Prince Charming they want
Superman to convert him into Clark Kent
and then how often does it happen
foreign Russell Wilson There You Go
Sierra's prayer meanwhile she's still up
in the Oscars half-assed naked that's
right the nerve of you Sierra grow up
you're a mother times two say Savannah
James look like we should be talking
about Savannah James way more than
Seattle Savannah James was the standard
on that Oscar's red carpet she owned it
it was hers she looked like a bride all
over again and I'm so proud of her and I
love her and I think she is every woman
needs to be following her because she
she's the epitome of femininity and a
wife and just being quiet and but but
but just she was powerful it just seeing
her I showed my daughters her and I just
said when I compared her to all the
other women that was on the red carpet
and my daughters were just like they
themselves I said what do you think they
said Savannah James just looks like I
mean like a queen like like just like
they they were just like is she getting
married again like like are they
renewing their vows because she just
excellence and even how she conducts her
family she is we need to stop talking
about the negativity I think so much and
focus on the women who are doing it
right because I don't think they get
enough of their flowers and women like
that who are really doing what they
should do but shout out to Savannah
James I just have to say if you guys
haven't seen her she just looks go to
her Instagram follow her if you can for
those that don't know Savannah James
LeBron James's wife so she came up to
the Oscars with a crazy looking yeah no
crumbs no crumbs in contrast to Russell
Wilson's wife Sierra so here's the thing
and I got to do a better job of this on
my channel as well as to continue to
promote the Savannah James continue to
avoid uh uh uh promote women such as
like Alicia Keys continue to promote
women that I think would be a fantastic
example of how to demonstrate yourself
out in the public we give way too much
Credence and relevance to the ones that
and they don't look they don't clean or
the ones that promote this independent
lifestyle what's so crazy is is that if
you look back to like Beyonce who's
creating Independent Women at the same
time of being married to Jay-Z
these famous women don't care about
y'all they appropriated being strong and
independent for the dollar and y'all
don't hold them accountable but y'all
hold us accountable
[Music]
accountable Yahoo Melanie accountable
Yahoo accountable you hold Maggie The
Substitute Teacher accountable that's
who y'all hold accountable but not the
ones that lie to y'all it makes
fundamentally no sense to me it but at
the same time modern women don't hold
modern women accountable
competition
who do you think is more afraid of
commitment men or women
personally I think women women
I think
it's a strange one because both sides
can be scared of commitment but I think
in the past women wanted to be more
committed speaking to my grandparents
great grandparents they always talked
about growing up how important it was
that they found man go dancing with them
marry them settle down have kids but
these days now I think women are too
scared
for commitment because they want to be
independent and be their own boss their
own future and I don't think I think
they always get maybe too scared to rely
on a man's money these days
what what do you think who's more afraid
of commitment men or women
I think men
if you want to Define commitment as
marriage
I think men making rational decisions uh
regarding long-term commitment should be
doing so in understanding the potential
negative repercussions for choosing
incorrect if you choose the incorrect
women that'll be one of the worst
decisions that you ever make in your
life why because men feel the brunt of
making an in correct decision if you
decide on a woman who
wants the false alligate
you suffer the consequences there's no
such thing as false allegations when it
comes to man on woman
if you decide to wake up on your head
every single day and you look to the
right of you and on your pillow is a
terrorist that makes your life a living
hell you're still guilty until proven
innocent
I think at the end of the day in
understanding the negative repercussions
in the family court system
and understanding what is going to
happen to you if you're the breadwinner
with alimony
with the child
managers making rational decisions
regarding commitment but at the same
time men today have so many other
options within that and this is the
scary thing if you look in a culture
such as Japan which has a rapidly
decreasing birth rate
in a level of technology that a Japan
has actually is more than the United
States you could be in a elevator five
floors down in a parking deck and still
get cell phone reception in Japan
but they utilize technology to the point
where
you can be in Japan and they have hug
parlors hmm
because men might need affection and
then they just go get a hug
to say that that will not be a reality
within our modern culture today within
America within North America within
Western cultures is not far outside the
reality and I think that's something
that has to be assessed they can buy
used panties out of a vendom and chains
in Japan yes use panties out of a
vending machine and they also uh is the
love dolls are the they are they are
innovating in terms of uh robotic
companionship but listen I always want
to finish the point real quick as well
if you look towards all of the forms of
entertainment that young men within
modern society today within Western
society today have they're coming up to
a real fundamental decision like bump
commitment marriage
let's just talk about dating if the
option is yo I can go over here and go
and see a Call of Duty LAN party with me
and my partners for the rest of this
Friday night and have a bang up time
shooting terrorists in the head versus
going on a date with a modern woman
today these men are making rational
decisions there are men that are making
rational decisions of should I stay in
tonight
beat off to the hub
instead of going out and deal with the
mouth of a modern woman like legit
they're making these rational decisions
and the technology today is bringing us
farther apart than closer together and
the thing is is like that's the point of
social media supposed to bring you
closer together but it's it's a foe it's
a far bringing closer together it's not
a closer together in reality and in fact
it's bringing us farther apart because
we have all of these short-term dopamine
driven
options
what do you think Melanie who's more
afraid of commitment men or women I
think men I think he's correct in terms
of who you want to talk about marriage
but if you want to talk about I I think
it's twofold I think if we're talking
about marriage it's going to be men just
because of the consequences that if it
doesn't work out and the responsibility
what it means to a man there's men have
very little benefits to being married uh
women have most of the benefits to being
married but I will say this in terms of
just like commitment relationships women
have more options in terms of swiping
right and they always the hypergamy and
and any they always want something
better something something better can
come along there why would I do I want
to settle with him because uh oh who
just popped in my DM
um it's it's actually
um you know and it will they they don't
want to tie themselves down because
somebody richer finer or something will
come along because it's easier for us to
just you know even unless you're like a
high level and famous and people women
Know Who You Are are you're not flooded
with DMS and women coming after you but
women even if you're an average woman
there's more men trying to come at you
and you never know who could be around
the corner and and even the dating apps
show this this is why women just will
constantly swipe left on the majority of
men that are out there and this is
supported by the data as well it was a
it was a um report that recently came
out that said that between the ages of
18 to 30 women report being in a in a
relationship 60-ish percent of the time
meanwhile men in the same age range
Report with being in a relationship 30
of the time
right so then the idea is is that most
women are dating older because it's not
within that specific age range or
lgbtq a right so if 20ish year old men
are going their own way
then this is something that has to be
looked at because our birth rate right
now in America is the lowest that has
been in like 40 years and we're catching
up to Japan
so we have to address these issues today
because if not you don't want to be in a
country with a rapidly declining birth
rate that's like being in a corporation
with a rapidly declining profit margin
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible